MINUTES LATE IN THAT
EARLY MESSAGE WITH THAT
HE'S LOOKING UP SAYING HOW DID
THAT NOT GO IN THE
HIS FOURTH NHL GAME.
COMING OFF THE GOAL LINE,
AND THIS ONE FOR ERIKSSON-EK.
HIS 10th GOAL OF THE SEASON
ALREADY.
YOU LOOK AT THIS ONE HER.
AROUND MERRILL.
SMACKED OUT OF MID-AIR BY GOGOL.
NUGENT-HOPKINS STEPS IN.
A SHOT.
SAVED CAM TALBOT AND THE REBOUND
A JUICY ONE.
RESSIVE
ON THE FOREC
MISSING SIX.
HYMAN, WHEELS AROUND.
FIND
GREENWAY ABLE TOITTLE MOVE.
ALA.
HASN'T B B FOR
MINNESOTA AND SECOND ONE ON LOST
COVERAGE ON T TTHE
MOST UNDERRATED PLAYERS IN THE
LEAGUE.
HYMAN GIVES ITT TALBOT ON THE
FIRST ONE.
LITTLE SKATE TO STICK WITH THEH.
LO
TALBOT.
>> Louie: THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
YOU WANT.
AN ICING CALL FOR THE MINNESOTA
WILD.
THE TOP LINE JUMPS OVER THE  AW.
GETS HIS
FLFL
INSIDE A MINUTE.
>> Louie: THOUGHT NUGENT-HOPKIN
>> Louie: GREAT SECOND PERIOD
FOR EDMONTON.
GET A GOAL AND MAKE IT  THAT WIR
CLASSIC IN WIWI
FOLIGNO THERE WITH SUPPORT.TO H.
AND INN HE ZIPS THAT BACK ACROSR
OF KOSKINEN.
>> Jack: ANOTHER ICING CALL.
BUT LOUIE
VICTOR RASK WHO SCORED
MINNESOTA's THIRD GOAL EARLIER
ON THE TAPE OF KULIKOV. IN A R
THE BEGINNING